y
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta edición
especial de la entrevista en france 24
hoy con el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de ucrania dmitro culeba nos
acompaña desde ucrania muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros señor culeba
quiero empezar con la situación en la
ciudad portuaria de mariupol un segundo
intento de extraer civiles por
corredores humanitarios este domingo
fracaso vladimir putin culpa a las
autoridades ucranianas que pasó
bueno no somos nosotros fue vladimir
putin el que atacó a ucrania y sitio la
ciudad de mariupol es él quien usa
aviones para lanzar bombas sobre
mariupol oms
destruye infraestructura civil mata
gente entonces porque ucrania no estaría
interesada en evacuar a sus compatriotas
de este sitio tan terrible claro que
estamos dispuestos pero infortunadamente
el ejército ruso no mantuvo su palabra
el canal no funcionó work
intentar la evacuación otra vez es muy
peligroso
cuando se cree que los rusos no quiere
que ocurra la evacuación
haremos tantos intentos como sea
necesario porque para nosotros salvar
vidas es la prioridad
y
hay otra ciudad portuaria bajo amenaza
parece el presidente excelencia y dijo
este domingo que hoy desa estaba
esperando un asalto ruso
esta información la tiene usted
y esto no es sólo un puerto es una
ciudad grande y hermosa con una historia
arquitectónica impresionante hace 100
años se hablaba francés en las calles si
la ciudad también está al borde del
ataque
y ahora se prepara para defenderse
nuestra marina en fuerzas armadas y los
civiles de la defensa territorial están
listos para defender la promesa rusa es
ruso el strike in the air' pues el
problema es que rusia está atacando con
inclemencia con cohetes y bombas y están
matando indiscriminadamente a civiles es
difícil luchar en contra de algo así
wright warriors o expecting van assouw
esperan también un asalto sobre kirk en
los próximos días
fighting
en interrupción el combate equipo
continúa sin interrupciones
infortunadamente el norte x el área de
combate activo y
combate
nuestras fuerzas han repelido
exitosamente ataques rusos pero el
ejército ruso manda cada vez más
recursos más tanques y soldados para
capturar la ciudad
así que su meta es controlar la capital
por keiko
walker en fort no fly zone media mente
ustedes están pidiendo zonas de
exclusión aérea la otan se ha negado
eeuu se ha negado los poderes
occidentales se han negado que tanto
pueden resistir sin esas zonas de
exclusión
y
tenemos pilotos valientes que están
listos para despegar y combatir
bombarderos rusos pero necesitamos avión
si la otan está rechazando las zonas de
exclusión para salvar vidas civiles
deberían suministrar los cazas y aviones
de ataque para asegurar nuestros cielos
si esto no pasa en nuestros aviones son
derrumbados por los rusos la
responsabilidad de lo que pasa en tierra
la destrucción del ejército ruso
extendido de mersing
destrucción la responsabilidad será
compartida entre los rusos y los que no
nos colaboraron le respondió de tipo de
research between the radiance han dado
subir noticias
esto significa que han perdido esperanza
en zonas de exclusión es world provar
you with fire te esperan que la otan les
de aviones de combate
si hubiera perdido la esperanza no
estaríamos hablando en este momento
fuentes estamos trabajando de toda
manera posible para respaldar o kranjcar
el punto es que si la otan no está lista
para establecer zonas de exclusión
debería darnos una solución alternativa
ese es mi punto
anthony blake
el secretario de estado- anthony blinken
con quien usted se reunió en la frontera
con polonia ayer dijo hoy que hubo una
luz verde hacia los países de la otan
para ofrecerles aeronaves este es correr
y happening are you
y esto ya está ocurriendo están
recibiendo jets o los van a recibirlo
no no estamos recibiendo los aún y no
estoy al tanto de ninguna decisión final
en ese sentido
otra opción sería que los aviones
ucranianos usaran aeropuertos en países
vecinos de la otan es esta una opción
que están buscando
creo que esa pregunta debería hacérsela
a nuestros expertos militares
yo tengo mucha experticia y mi trabajo
es asegurarme de que los socios tomen
decisiones políticas sobre los
suministros de armas imponer sanciones a
rusia y respaldar a ucrania con ayuda
humanitaria pero los detalles técnicos
quien vuela desde donde es algo que debe
considerar nuestro personal de defensa
the sunday hablando de sanciones blinken
también dijo que los aliados están
teniendo discusiones activas sobre
evitar la importación de gas y petróleo
ruso
jones
esta sería una sanción drástica are you
calling future and you have o están
pidiendo esto guardan la esperanza de
que pase
the words
de una guerra en medio de europa la peor
desde la segunda guerra mundial el país
está siendo destruido con aviones
cohetes y misiles
que mueren civiles y niños no entiendo
cómo teniendo tal guerra en europa
todavía alguien compra petróleo y gas
ruso
por eso es que le pedimos a todos los
europeos norteamericanos y otros países
que dejen de comprar petróleo y gas ruso
porque huele a sangre ucraniano
en gas es más luz y creyendo
para que esto pueda pasar
obviamente esto tiene consecuencias
económicas para muchos países de europa
occidental espera que tomen esos pasos
en los próximos días
[Música]
ground y creo que hay un fundamento
moral sólido para que los países
europeos tomen esa decisión para parar
la guerra no significa que sea una
decisión final y por siempre pero es una
medida para detener la guerra
para demostrarle el presidente putin que
puede perder todos sus ingresos por
petróleo y gas
yo creo que es una obligación moral de
los europeos si ucrania falla quiero ser
claro si falla putin se sentirá
suficientemente envalentonado para
seguir con su guerra híbrida e
incrementarla en contra de europa hungry
es más barato apoyar a ucrania ahora que
detener a putin luego
vladimir putin tuvo otra conversación
con el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón el domingo dijo el presidente
francés que perseguiría la meta rusa ya
sea a través de negociaciones
de la guerra
hablando de negociaciones su trabajo
debería haber una tercera ronda de
negociaciones entre ucrania y rusia en
la frontera con belarús este lunes
los desarrollos discutidos en esta
entrevista tiene alguna esperanza de que
las negociaciones puedan ser exitosas
bueno soy un diplomático como no voy a
tener esperanzas en las negociaciones
hemos insistido por esta ronda de
negociaciones pero el éxito depende de
un factor de que rusia negocio en buena
fe sin dictar ultimátum sino buscando
soluciones aceptables mutuamente si kim
wilson descartando sus soluciones
y sobre las primeras dos rondas de
negociaciones y lo que ha pasado
recientemente van a seguir hablando o
dirán en cierto punto que lo que dicen
los rusos en la mesa de negociaciones no
pasa en el terreno y dejarán de hablar
y
la naturaleza de la diplomacia en cada
conflicto es que debe seguirse
negociando mientras haya la más mínima
posibilidad de lograr un éxito
es cierto no vemos la correlación en el
sostenimiento de las charlas y la
intensidad de los combates en el terreno
rusia no se detiene no detiene sus
fuerzas mientras las delegaciones
negocian sin embargo tenemos que
mantener el camino diplomático con vida
[Música]
pero cuando vladimir putin dice que en
su perspectiva ucraniano existe el hace
lo que dice los
granger
y bueno los ucranianos son los judíos
del siglo 21 el presidente putin sigue
la misma lógica de adolf hitler en los
treinta y cuarenta por tres
y cree que no tenemos derecho a existir
y está buscando una solución final al
problema craneano préstamos luchando y
el blitzkrieg lanzado por el presidente
putin en contra nuestra fracaso ahora
está lanzando más y más soldados rusos a
ucrania a que mueren
y
rusia ha sufrido alrededor de 10.000
bajas en ucrania casi tantas como las
sufridas en la guerra de chechenia
luchamos porque entendemos estamos
luchando por nuestra tierra por nuestro
país por nuestro derecho a ser
ucranianos rodean
rangers
en una conversación con el presidente
francés vladimir putin también dijo que
ucrania es responsable por lo que
denominó una provocación cerca de la
planta nuclear de sap orilla cuál es su
respuesta
bueno si los tanques rusos disparan a la
planta nuclear si una unidad militar
ataca y toma control de la planta
es decir que ucrania es responsable es
una distorsión total de la realidad todo
distorsión
le preocupa que él pueda atacar otras
plantas nucleares en ucrania ese es su
plan usted que cree
creo que hay un riesgo no sé si sea
parte de su plan pero podría serlo
definitivamente
antes de concluir hay planes de
contingencia para el presidente selenski
o su gobierno si hay un asalto completo
sobre quiere verse en hit full flat
south oak cliff maybe que posiblemente
gobernar desde otro país u otro lugar
country
[Música]
ya hay un asalto completo sobre equipo
pero el presidente se queda ahí junto
con el pueblo de kif
[Música]
no estoy al tanto de ningún plan de
contingencia no estamos considerando esa
opción porque vemos como lucha la gente
ucraniana por su país bajo el liderazgo
del presidente es el lencero
no dudo que vamos a prevalecer la
pregunta es el precio y si recibimos el
respaldo necesario de nuestros socios en
armas y sanciones esto nos permitirá
salvar muchas vidas de ahorrar mucho
tiempo si no ocurre el precio será mayor
e infortunadamente como ya dije los
socios deberán compartir
responsabilidades por las muertes de
civiles inocentes seguiremos luchando
hasta prevalecer brooklyn
como conclusión tiene algún mensaje para
el pueblo francés para la gente de
occidente y el resto del mundo
ripoll ue o under systems espero que el
pueblo francés entienda que la causa por
la cual pelean ucrania es una causa
justa y que respalde nuestra resistencia
hacia el agresor que nos odia que nos
quiere destruir debe ser urge esas
historias
pero somos suficientemente fuertes para
luchar contra él y prevalecer estén del
lado correcto de la historia estén con
nosotros
señor culeba muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en esta entrevista de
france 24 esperamos mejores tiempos para
usted y para su país a ustedes también
gracias
[Música]